So excited to try out this new camera from wise.
Going on a trip soon and I need to make sure I can
see what's going on in my backyard.
It is. Camera moves 3 60
and that it's weather resistant is just perfect
what I need.
I'm also super impressed with the picture quality
and how easy it was to install.
Just look how it rotates 3 60.
When I'm away from the homestead
I really wanna be able to
see what's going on with the animals.
And this camera even tracks the animals.
Look, it's tracking my cow
so I can be
anywhere in the world and keep an eye on my baby.
It even follows the dogs in the backyard.
I can keep an eye on everyone.
And with the app I can record and save any clips.
I have other cameras
and I'm super impressed with this one.
And with the price you can't beat it.